so we got a lot of requests to talk to
you guys about the guardians of the
galaxy trailer I was sure to watch it it
just premiered here are my thoughts
instantly wow that looks good I'm blown
away by how this movie looks I am so
surprised at the tone this movie is
going for because I gotta be honest I
don't really know much about the
guardians of the galaxy source material
I'm not gonna act like I do cuz I don't
I'm a big comic book fan I'm a big
Marvel and DC fan but guardians of
galaxy was never one that I was very
well-versed in my only introduction to
it was the end credits scene of Thor the
dark world and I gotta be honest the end
credits scene of Thor the dark world
really had me scratching my head and I
wasn't really that excited for this
movie this trailer though turned me
around completely I love the tone
they're going for it looks very funny
and totally different I've got a little
bit of a Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy feel from this trailer Chris
Pratt looks great as star-lord this kind
of guy who seems to think he's more
awesome than he is that's at least the
vibe I get from this trailer rocky
racoon is gonna be voiced by Bradley
Cooper you don't really get to hear his
voice at all in this trailer but he
looks awesome
Vin Diesel as Groot this big guy looks
like a giant walking tree overall I am
just interested in the tone they're
going for because this is so different
from your average comic book movie and I
find that extremely enticing as a viewer
who's used to so many comic book movies
nowadays adaptations for comic books and
graphic novels are happening left and
right now adays there are so many of
them are actually getting kind of
congested I love me a comic book movie
but yes there is kind of starting to get
a bit of a cliched tone to them a lot of
them are starting to be a little bit
similar this one looks pretty different
and pretty awesome and for that reason I
am now extremely excited to see this
movie the special effects look good
looks very funny john c reilly is in it
that's always a plus
overall I cannot believe how awesome
this trailer looked because I really had
no anticipation for this movie until now
and now I am completely hyped for this
movie what did you guys think of it are
you excited for it do you think it
reaches the tone of the comics if you
are well versed in the comics do you
think it looks like it's honoring that
because that's something that I can't
really comment on because as I said not
that well versed in them nevertheless
I'm very excited to see what this movie
goes it's looking a lot better than I
thought it was going to be let me know
thought below and as always if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck with nice